bonjour tout le monde ça va besoin alors
bravo voyez j'ai juste de me réveiller
mais je suis déjà à l'arraché restée
presse il faut voilà j'ai un site
d'arrivée au studio one vient de poster
la photo en moins d'une minute me like
jette et est cette fille commence à
culoz détestant fait ça veut dire
qu'elle est c'est acté a dicté par tabac
tue à planter ta voiture huit fois ce
mois-ci ya aujourd'hui mes posts ont
généré plus d'un millier de black et
pour moi c'est ça qui fait la vie c'est
bien pour quelque chose qui a du succès
sur les réseaux sociaux pas la vie qui
paie mes factures de stream tally plus
grande j'espère que vous allez bien
berthier ski lara non je crois qu'on
devrait paraître qu'est ce qui te prend
calme-toi tout est sous contrôle
oui mon portable tu vas aller dans un
endroit où il n'y a pas de raisons
poussent à jupiter
[Musique]
et je crois que dans les films c'est là
où tu te souviens que ça fait très
longtemps que tu attendais ce moment et
on s'embrasse
aujourd'hui tu va m'aider à l'atelier et
votre petite fille elle s'habitue
[Musique]
j'ai enfin je m'appelle la marge les
raccompagner lâché elle risque et
imagine comment et ma vie des milliers
de personnes me suivre sur les réseaux
et moi ce que je fais tous les jours
mais y'en a pas une seule qui me connaît
vraiment je veux trouver ma voie faire
quelque chose qui m'intéresse vraiment
et apprendre à mieux me connais ma
chérie mieux se connaître c'est le
meilleur moyen de se détester monde sait
que chez kuhn snobinarde irresponsable
non je suis pas d'accord c'est pas vrai
tu dis ça mais c'est parce que tu me
connais pas trop encore
[Musique]